anime characters aren't the smartest
bunch when it comes to risk assessment
most of them at least for every
magnificent chess master you'll probably
get a horde of hot-blooded go-getters
that punch jump and boast before they
think it makes sense since anime is
supposed to be fixtured and a lot of
these people especially if their
protagonist simply brush aside all
possible consequences then there are
these guys these people who instantly
regret their actions only for it to be
too late sucks to be them you know today
we'll be going over some of my memorable
instant regrets in anime whether it be
punching above your weight class trash
talking the godliest being in the
universe or simply conscience getting in
the way and leading to severe
consequences
scavenger versus accelerator starts off
our list
is
in anime there exists the villains that
pose the real threat you know they're
trouble and you know they'll also be the
ones to undergo long winding redemption
arcs that make them fan favorites even
more accelerator is one of those then
there are those villains who form some
quirky mini boss squad the characters
that occasionally pose a threat but end
up being more of some shades of a team
rocket-like group sure they can find
themselves higher up in the totem pole
than the actual joke villains but that's
the ceiling for them scavenger is one of
those too bad they don't realize this
when they get asked to stop accelerator
despite all their talking up about
themselves all their combination attacks
mean nothing against academy city's
strongest and accelerator makes short
work of them taking them down one by one
as the leader watches in horror it's not
even a fight it's more like a massacre
and most embarrassing of all leader ends
up wetting herself when all said and
done
[Applause]
beware the nice ones they say and that
can't be any truer for gone it's not
hard to see why people tend to pick on
gun unlike both gura pika and killua he
doesn't seem to hide a murderous streak
he's happy carefree and has quirky
powers but only us fans know and
understand the darkness and rage that
hides underneath that facade morale
certainly doesn't and that shows in his
haughty attitude when testing gone even
going as far as provoking the guy to
rage just to have him fight seriously
gone with the intent to kill is truly a
monster in all sense we know that having
watched the show but it's also fun to
see gone making people regret wrong
assumptions in early hunter hunter and
every time he makes people pay for
looking down on him it's a gratifying
moment you wouldn't want to experience
the full wrath of the monster that lies
within
next up we have assassin vs gilgamesh in
fate zero
[Music]
um
assassin runs into gilgamesh it's all a
ruse on the part of the evil priest but
we've got to give some props for all the
effort in being assassin's biggest hype
man leading up to this moment he props
assassin up and builds his confidence
sending him off to kill tokiomi in a
mission that's supposedly super easy for
him now we all know how that ends up
assassin does get the infiltration part
halfway done but as for fighting archer
didn't quite go his way now did it no
need to fear archer kirei said that's
funny but i don't think assassin found
it funny when he got turned into
mincemeat by the strongest servant of
them all with gilgamesh spouting one of
his many signature badass boasts while
towering over the servants he's so
casually destroyed no wonder gilgamesh
ends up being so arrogant it takes an
insane amount of willpower to not get
caught up in your own hype when you're
that powerful
[Music]
was full of hype but even all that top
booking is nothing against saitama
after the excellent showing he had ever
since his debut in one punch man it's
clear as day that garo is being poised
to be the next big villain a lot of
people bought it and he himself brought
it into his own hype i mean having taken
down hero after hero without even so
much as breaking a sweat garo stocks
must be at an all-time high at this
point then he also runs into some bottom
feeder no name guy in the streets thus
garo does the smart thing and hits this
random scrub the hardest he can enough
to cause cracks on the ground too bad
this random scrub is none other than
saitama and he gets paid back in kind
just like all the arrogant villains
before him garo gets dealt the signature
one hit knockout one punch his all side
diamond needs but this doesn't even
qualify as a serious punch a chop is all
it takes to cut garo down to size
before we move on to the next entry on
the list i'd like to take this time to
thank today's sponsors expressvpn vpns
are aplenty so how do we determine the
best vpn of them all i think the ease of
use is the biggest factor an expressvpn
has that title one no questions asked
with the ability to access so many
different servers from across the globe
bypassing region locks and protecting
your identity has never been this easy
you don't need to be a tech wizard to
make this work i use it just this
weekend to watch hunter hunter which
isn't available in the uk all i had to
do was open up expressvpn and select the
united states server and boom now i can
watch hunter hunter like dozens of other
anime on netflix break region locks
overcome villains trying to get your
personal info and surf without suffering
any slowdowns in internet speed so
what's not to like no other vpn i've
used comes anywhere close to expressvpn
in terms of effectiveness ease of access
and value for money you can get three
months of expressvpn for free by
following the link below or typing in
www
x
vinnie tube a world of safe browsing and
an internet free of limitations are at
your fingertips now back to the show
it's about time to feature parasite in
one of these lists so we have shinichi
versus the bullies
bullies aren't exactly the most
self-aware people in the world all that
power and influence quickly seep into
your brain and remove your sense of
danger they find themselves unable to
recognize when they're punching above
their weight class and they rightfully
suffer the consequences of doing so in
some other scenario they would have
gotten away with it in this moment
however what they didn't account for is
the fact that shinichi is no longer just
an ordinary dweeb that they can push
around this is now a guy who's been
enhanced with unimaginable power
allowing him to easily block the
toughest punches and pay them back in
kind shinichi has become a monster and
he had no qualms letting these bullies
know about it we're all thankful he's on
humanity's side right
i'm beginning to see a pattern here gone
saitama shinichi truth in television
it's the nice goofy looking people
getting underestimated in those three
scenarios and we continue that role with
mob just like the three mob has never
been one to flaunt his power it makes
sense considering how different of a
role he has compared to gilgamesh and
accelerator who are villains or fringe
allies at worst in one of the most
memorable moments of mob psycho we have
hanazava here who's a ball of fire a
wave of momentum going up against mob
what can dorky old mob do against the de
facto leader of the school one full of
gang wars that pose no threat to
hanazava whatsoever he developed quite
an ego as a result too but unfortunately
for him that ego wasn't enough to defeat
mob and he got destroyed in a straight
up humiliating fashion his psychic
powers were quickly overwhelmed by mob
and he finally learned his lesson after
being embarrassed the way he did how
could you not learn your lesson
kicking and these thugs are no exception
it feels good to be able to talk about
durarara quite a nice show that people
seem to have forgotten about in the
passage of time but it's my turn to
remind you of how badass shizuo is this
guy eats fights for breakfast and he's
the type of angry dude who will beat
people up just for looking at him only
fools will dare challenge this monster
to a fight but the thugs in ikibaguro
can't seem to read the notice the most
glaring example is this idiot he who
dares smash shizuo's head with a bat
people indeed lose all sensibilities in
the face of fear and they pay hard for
it shizuo no sells the shot and sends
the receipt back in a big way punching
the guy right to the sky eradicating him
and his clothes in the process that
should teach these thugs to pick their
fights and never mess with just anyone
especially not a good old bartender who
lives and breathes fights
sakura failing to destroy the rinigun is
such a vital point in the final arc
here's a rare heroic example of
characters regretting their actions
instantly and it must be poor sakura in
the spotlight to be fair i don't think
that she would have gotten as much flack
as she did when the anime version of the
scene aired still it doesn't make it any
less of an instant regret because
everyone knows so much could have been
prevented had she been quick enough to
do it it really does go both ways in my
opinion on one hand sakura didn't have
the mental fortitude to carry on with it
as quickly as she should she also took
her sweet time arguing with obito
costing them valuable time on the other
hand it's freaking mad she's racing
against the anime extended this scene
compared to the manga but in the manga
the whole thing happened in such a
shorter span of time it's really a
wasted opportunity that i'm pretty sure
would have haunted me to kingdom come
had i been in sakura's shoes at least i
can console myself by thinking it can't
be avoided when i'm tasked to race with
what people can say to be naruto's
versions equivalent of utsuru or aizen
besides he would never have been weaker
but given how broken he is moderate
would have still done tons of damage had
sakura succeeded
lastly we have a big moment from tokyo
revenges featuring everyone's favorite
leader mikey
mikey has quickly become the fan
favorite amongst the tokyo revenge's
characters and why wouldn't he be he
plays the role of the cool leader type
to perfection and a good leader is
someone you can trust to have your back
even in the direst of situations someone
who can turn things around an exact
divine retribution on arrogant slobs you
know people like hanma a bloody and
beaten up mikey is still a force to be
reckoned with but hanuman doesn't seem
to know that he continues with his
arrogant posturing completely oblivious
to the danger he's put himself in well
there's a kick that would surely teach
him a lesson one kick is all it takes
and just as mikey so nonchalantly claims
it's all over it's nothing short of
satisfying seeing everyone flee in fear
as they say a war gets decided when the
leaders take on each other and as one
falls so does the rest of the group
that just about wraps up my favorite
instant regret moments in anime some
sweet moments there don't you think if
you enjoyed the video please check out
my channel for more content i've got
videos on a lot of things mostly catered
to shonen fans best mentor entrances top
fights biggest showcases of power you
name it you can also check out vinitube
kai my other channel that caters more
towards video essays than this that
revolve around specific titles oh and
don't forget to drop by our social media
if you've got the time to discord
instagram and patreon are all open we're
also exploring other possible avenues to
keep in touch with the community so
please stay tuned that's it for this
week i hope you had fun and if you
haven't done it yet please subscribe so
you can be alerted the next time i
upload a video thanks for watching